there are several things in the news
right now where people that have a sense
of entitlement they feel like they are
do something are quote having their say
obviously the Occupy Wall Street folks
fall into that category the the same
folks same group of folks are the ones
that are saying if I work at McDonald's
I'm you $15 an hour and we're gonna head
to a fast-food strike the wealth
equality movement has at its core a
entitlement mentality because I'm
entitled to have the same level of
wealth as you you're not special you've
not worked harder you're not smarter
you're not more talented than me and so
I'm due to have exactly the same amount
of wealth that you have and it's unfair
that you have more than I have all of
those have it to its core this
entitlement thing and this entitlement
thing is raising up in our culture and
for those of us that are on the opposite
end of the spectrum it's pretty
disturbing to us because it it smacks of
a lack of personal responsibility it
smacks of a lack of initiative it says
that somehow that the only way to fix
things is a governmental fix which would
be communism basically taking over all
of our assets and thereby redistributing
them to the entitled ones that don't
have the assets and haven't done
anything to earn the assets so this
entitlement spirit is a disturbing
spirits I've been thinking about it
because in light of the smart money
smart kids book and all the speaking
we've been doing on teaching kids how to
handle money I'm thinking about where
does the spirit come from and really
what is the antidote to it because I got
to tell you it's highly unattractive I
mean the idea that you're do something
that you didn't do anything to get
that you look up in your own third-base
and somebody sent you there and you feel
like you hit a triple is an unattractive
character quality highly unattractive so
why would we ever want our kids to have
this mentality because in the
marketplace they're not marketable in
the marketplace people don't reward this
I'm do something even though I haven't
done anything to get that thing
mentality it's attractive I think the
opposite of it is probably gratitude
there's an arrogance to entitlement and
there is a sense of humility gratitude
gratitude says thank you
thank you for being my customer thank
you for allowing me to serve your table
thank you for giving me a job that
allows me to feed my family and buy
electricity for my kids and Heating and
Cooling from our home thank you for
working for me and working with me on my
team and I'm going to say thank you by
the way I pay you and the way the things
I do for you if you're one of my team
members working on my team thank you
thank you Lord for the blessings that
you poured into my life thank you is an
incredible expression of gratitude and I
got to tell you it's highly attractive
to think about a child in your presence
that doubles up their fists and his
red-faced and acts like they deserve
something and has a little temper fit
versus the child that smiles and says
thank you for what you've done for me
thank you for this gift thank you for
this birthday gift not having a fit
because the cake is the wrong color and
we've got a whole culture that's having
a hissy fit because their cake at their
birthday is the wrong color because they
think the axis of the world runs through
the center of their head so entitlement
has at its essence this sense of
arrogance so how do we combat that well
as I said in the corner of at the core
of gratitude is a sense of humility
versus arrogance and so it starts with
humility and humility can then lead to
gratitude and humility is not
humiliation humility is I understand my
place I understand that if I don't do
something nothing's going to happen
humility then can lead to gratitude and
by the way gratitude can lead to
contentment but you will never find
someone who is entitled who is content
think about that that's a little bit
profound if you work your way through it
and and so this idea of what we want to
teach our children are who we want to be
as people is I want to start with a
sense of humility
now humility is not I think less of
myself that's false humility humility is
CS Lewis said I think less of not I
think less of myself it's I think of
myself less I'm not was worried about me
it's not all about me that's a sense of
humility and so we need to work on that
ourselves we need to definitely have our
kids begin to understand that concept
which leads them to the ability to be
grad grateful because again if you want
to be a highly attractive human being be
a grateful human being
you